embrace reality and deal with it there
is nothing more important than
understanding how reality works and how
to deal with it the state of mind you
bring to this process makes all the
difference
I found it helpful to think of my life
as if it were a game in which each
problem I face is a puzzle I need to
solve by solving the puzzle I get a gem
in the form of a principle that helps me
avoid the same sort of problem in the
future collecting these gems continually
improves my decision-making so I'm able
to ascend to a higher level and higher
levels of play in which the game gets
harder and the stakes become even
greater all sorts of emotions come to me
while I'm playing and those emotions can
either help me or hurt me
if I can reconcile my emotions with my
logic and only act when they're aligned
I make better decisions learning how
reality works visualizing the things I
want to create and then building them
out is incredibly exciting to me
stretching for big goals puts me in a
position of failing and needing to learn
and come up with new inventions in order
to move forward
I find it exhilarating to be caught up
in the feedback loop of rapid learning
just as a surfer loves riding a wave
even though it sometimes leads to
crashes don't get me wrong I'm still
scared of crashes and I still find them
painful but I keep the pain in
perspective knowing that I will get
through these setbacks and that most of
my learning will come from reflecting on
them just as long-distance runners push
through the pain to experience the
pleasure of runner's high
I have largely gotten past the pain of
my mistake making and instead enjoy the
pleasure that comes with learning from
it I believe that with practice you can
change your habits and experience the
same mistake learners I